hey guys what's up it's Justine today
we're going to be opening up the brand
new years of war for Xbox one slim I am
pretty excited to check this out I've
seen a bunch of photos and it looks so
so sick
and fun fact my grandmother for the
longest time had the Gears of War Xbox
360 so she finally just upgraded to the
Xbox one and I'm so upset because gram
this could have been yours
I'm actually going to be hosting the
Gears of War for you support for stream
I can't say it fast
here's the world for Gears of War 4 so
before I start unboxing I've got some
good news
definitely good news for you guys I just
recently updated to the Xbox one slim
the white version so it seems that got
out I was like yes this is exciting the
bad news is if I kept this it would just
sit in my house and I don't want it to
go to waste
so I decided that I will give it away to
one of you guys so I'm gonna do a very
gentle unboxing so that I won't mess
anything up so that when I said it to
you guys all of the pieces will be here
so basically if you want to get this
Xbox one Gears of War 4 edition there's
only two things you have to do leave a
comment below on this youtube video and
tell me why you want this or what you're
going to do with it clearly you're gonna
play games on it so that's this really
stupid that should make you guys do take
a screenshots of your comment on youtube
and tweet it to me at I just een because
that's where I'm actually going to be
picking the winner and contacting you
because sometimes it's really hard to
pick people on YouTube because you think
it's fake or it's not fake but on
Twitter I'll be able to actually contact
you if you don't have a Twitter you
should probably get one because it's
been around for a long time also make
sure you're following me on Twitter
because if you send me a tweet and
you're not actually following me I'm
going to be very offended oh yeah you
want you want those like that's what
you're not following me I've got quality
tweets
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh baby so Microsoft did send me this to
check out so thank you guys I appreciate
it so let's just get it out of here
come out I have to do a very gentle
unbox I want to ensure that all of your
pieces are here just a nice little cut
right here and a nice little cut right
here this is gonna be the gentlest
unboxing you'll ever see
I just everything I'm doing if you're
like oh look at this a topo my a my open
a throw away here we go got this nice
little paper here shows me how to set up
my xbox it's pretty self-explanatory
I don't think you'll have a problem so
this looks to me your game code actually
yeah oh look at this oh and it's ink I'm
like the dark red version so this just
clips on to the side of your Xbox one or
it potentially could be the bottom so it
helps you stand it up so depending upon
which way you want to stand it the stand
will help you unbox after Reeboks boxes
mil empty what do we have in here ooh
the controller very very gentle with it
I'm using a nice red knife it's the only
red knife that I could find it is a
knockoff team valor knife this looks
real nice it's got a really nice matte
finish and right here on the d-pad
there's a little thumb print you guys
can see that little thumb print there
also these buttons look awesome
they have little like slashes on them so
they're not the usual typed font it's a
nice slashed font I really like the
attention to detail that they went into
on this controller I mean it wasn't
necessary to do these actual slashes so
right here these are indented into the
controller it's a nice little touch
speaking of touch go to put this back in
I don't want any of your items to get
lost
because you'll be like just seen
your boss my item HDMI cable listen here
cord so you guys haven't been up to date
on the new Xbox one slim you do not have
a power Rick any longer it is internal
which definitely saves a lot of space
open up and see the Xbox one in all its
glory it's so much thinner than the
other ones I'm being so very very
careful oh wow
Xbox one model 1681 hello from Seattle
can you see it okay I don't know if it's
focusing or not but that's what it says
oh they even went so far as the slashes
on the actual consoles so these are
invented into the plastic looks good oh
it's really good dude I'm actually quite
envious that I decided to already give
this away but I definitely do not need
another Xbox oh I just want somebody
else who could actually put this to good
use to put it to good use
it is beautiful so when I favorite
things though in the new Xbox one of us
is that they have a USB port in the
front because I'd always be like
reaching around to the side and trying
to it's just it's much better much
better placement here so it's great this
will look good either way that you
decide to set it because the back also
has this nice detail as does the front
now let's see if I can wrap this back up
the way that they had it
[Music]
so just reading on this paper that this
is one of the new Xbox one wireless
controllers so what's great about this
is it has bluetooth built into it so
you'll be able to use this not only on
your Xbox but you'll also be able to use
it on your Windows 10 PC so something
that I'm pretty excited about with gears
is a lot of the new and upcoming Xbox
one games will be available not only for
Xbox but they will also be available on
Windows 10 and for me this is pretty
great
I just always travel with my xbox but at
this point it became too much of a
struggle to be able to lug an Xbox a dog
plus all the clothes and electronics and
gadgets they started turning into this
pack red person who basically was
carrying everything with them everywhere
they went so now instead of bringing all
of this stuff if I'm like desperate to
play a game I'll be able to play on one
my Windows 10 laptops which is pretty
exciting so that is the new Gears of War
for Xbox one I look forward to seeing
you guys in the live stream on Wednesday
and look forward to seeing your guys's
reactions to playing the game I just
started the campaign I got an early look
at the game the problem is I was trying
to play some of the online modes and no
one else is on so I can't wait until the
game is actually out and I get to play
with you guys don't forget if you guys
want to get a chance to get this Xbox
one all you have to do is leave a
comment below on why you should get it
then take a screenshot of your comment
that you posted on youtube and tweet it
to me on Twitter and of course it's just
a kind gesture that you be subscribed to
my channel and would be following me on
Twitter because I think that's just a
nice thing to do I'll see you guys later
so guys have a great week I'll see you
soon bye I can't believe I just did an
unboxing Anna blue boxing Oh
like it really is a very pretty device
okay put this immediately back into its
case immediately Oliver wants to know if
I have any Halloween videos planned I
actually have a week of Halloween